c хлопчик громадян інвока британії
вин тут народу вся його бочки поляка і
зараз він муркочеш
отримати британських рам агенство червоною
більше не хоче вмістити пресі бать
капустина читаючи статті про 1000 поляк і
мошенник
які вище explode затишок систему соціального
забезпечення країни можна сказати ще
коли читаю статті на до речі і сим вони
просто дорослому склепіння
яви чого я гнів і ненависть і абсолютно
не виділяю таких твердинь сили ширини
полю негативні емоції все-таки
Великобританія стала іншу думу
для чином менше дев'яти ста тисяч
поляків інженер переїхавши до
Великобританії немає 10 рокер тому
засіки через тисячу зарплат ним вин
занепалого вся добрий інтегрованим і мовляв
але й культурно, проте волосово несе про
brexit сенс її візьміть свою думку
пепермінт підшивається тут побожним.
кінцю офіс перший я вступав у дискусії
я мати без розуму ти багатий аргумент
ось на кнс перебувала пильні мови
ранніх такоякі та вимагати с.м. така
була шана ще думають про нас британці
лазера що демони розчарувала все
будете виконати ваш показах ви
золотинка ми близько 120 тисяч поляків
може повернутий сяду шукає
Великобританії брата гунера 1 ст.
зруби счп уроку тому
його вона задавала щодо рубала такий
курок ланки настрій у голову британії
її душа за бентежна як не голівняка
початку було позитивно атмосфера
тільки вид криту Європи за зустрічалася
з ведмедиком і казав і ласка питанням у а
потім на шляху їм самим
раб там хрюкнути ви рем апарат вашим
кути ніж з здавалося через до побачення
ми її польські знаю світ сповідають ч на
трояндами чому хропіння там спочивала так
100 тис а реван полюбіть біля пошти нині
видно сну низький ще правда економіка
стала [ __ ] на стабільну з приходом до
влада партії право і справедливість
інвестиції скручуються алла поляка та
типу varta ються не skoda і віджати тут
он і не підшиває собою
своїми